what are your best party tricks we've
gone apart from lighting our own farms
i didn't say i do it i just said that
people do it people do it yeah
um someone assists you with that
well
um the night of the premiere i know what
i'll be doing
[Music]
what is your cocktail of choice snake
bite in black
what is a snake
it's lager and cider and black currant
they were banned in my student union um
[Laughter]
i like a martini what kind of martini
do you get
let's try it out straight up
i don't care if it's shaken if it's
stirred as long as it's cold
it's got lots of olives in it more i
mean like a pile of olives i mean it's
like that's usually dinner
i grew up in los angeles so we just have
an affinity for for tequila of course
being so close to mexico's i'm a big
tequila connoisseur what was your
biggest star struck moment and with whom
go on you knock it oh boy
that is a good question that is a good
question apart from me obviously yeah no
i i was pretty taken aback yeah yeah it
wasn't
for all sorts of other reasons
oh
boy denzel was one i mean the first time
i worked with julia roberts i was she
came and i was playing a student in her
classroom and she sat on my desk uh and
in between takes and just said hey how
are you doing like tell me a little bit
about yourself and yeah that took me a
beat to respond that smile forget about
it yeah
yours catherine de nerve
venice in 2000 i was with some pretty
heavy hitters it was tom hanks and i was
sat in a room and they all sat in front
of me
and someone came into the room and they
all got up and i went oh right okay
right and i turned around i saw it was
catherine de nerve and i just stood up
and i just went
and got all kind of like
like
a gog a gog yeah
what are your best party tricks
apart from when we've bought apart from
lighting our own farms
uh i said it said now it's out there
it's out there i didn't say i do it i
just said that people
the night of the premiere i know what
i'll be doing
not falling over is my best party trick
yeah yeah i've managed to stay on my own
two feet it's my best party trick i'm
i'm i'm the same man just uh yeah tr try
to be a fly in the wall get out your get
out the guitar and sing something yeah
of course
three or four songs i wrote the amount
of times exactly yeah the amount of
times people are like wait get a little
drunk they're like can you play that too
and you're like what tune what tune
would that be yeah like you know
something from uh
that band yeah what job would you be
doing if you weren't an actor
ooh
i mean have you thought about this a lot
not recently no not recently but a lot
in the past out of necessity i i nearly
was a number of things back in the day
yeah i nearly ended up on the qe2 at one
point as a as a waiter
um and i think i'd probably still be
there with a great tan
i may add
who is your favorite villain in movie
history
wow wow that goes uh
third man um awesome wells i absolutely
love
javier bardem in skyfall but for me
uh
anton sugar in no country for old men
that character still haunts me
did you do any of your own stunts in
shangti and the legend of the ten rings
zero i did absolutely none of my own
stunts and anything more than a brisk
walking pace i uh i flat out refused i
went to my trailer and i said let the
double do it is that a joke that's a
total joke yeah i did i did uh i did
quite a few of my own stunts i mean i
mean you know that's part of the joy of
getting to do movies like this is you
get to
you know be a part of the action and uh
and i definitely wanted to do as much as
i could so